ONLY A CHRISTMAS MIRACLE WILL
SAVE THEIR PROSPECTS IN THE NEW
YEAR.
JOINING ME WITH REACTION IS DAN
BONGINO, AUTHOR OF THE BOOK
EXONERATED ALONG WITH CHRIS HAHN
AN AID TO SENATOR CHUCK SCHUMER
AND HOST OF A POD CAST.
THE CREW WILL TELL ME WHEN THEY
HAVE THE SHOTS READY BECAUSE I
WANT TO SHARE THOSE WITH YOU.
DAN, YOUR REACTION TO THE NOTION
THAT WHATEVER NADLER AND THE
DEMs ARE PLANNING, ALL OF THIS
IMPEACHMENT DRAMA WILL IT GET
LOST IN THE HOLIDAY HUHBUB?
>> IT'S ALREADY LOST.
THE ATTENTION SPAN OF MOST
PEOPLE IS THEIR TWITTER FEED ON
ONE SCROLL.
THERE WAS A NOTHING BURGER FROM
THE START.
THERE WAS NOTHING THERE.
WITH CLINTON WE HAD ACTUALLY
PERJURY.
WHETHER IMPEACHING WAS A GOOD
POLITICAL IDEA.
WITH NIXON AN ACTUAL BURGLARLY
HAPPENED.
THIS WAS ALLEGED QUID PRO QUO
AND IT KEEPS CHANGING.
IT WAS ABOUT MILITARY AID AND
THEN A WHITE HOUSE MEETING AND
THEN A PUBLIC STATEMENT.
THIS IS A POLITICAL DISASTER FOR
THE DEMOCRATS.
>> CHRIS, YOUR REACTION TO THIS?
OBVIOUSLY THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO
ARE GOING TO DEBATE WHETHER
THERE ARE GROUNDS FOR
IMPEACHMENT.
WILL THE HOLIDAY SEASON PLAY A
ROLE IN THIS TRYING TO PITCH
THIS IMPEACHMENT IN THE MIDDLE
OF THE HOLIDAY?
>> WELL, EVERYTHING GETS LOST IN
THE HOLIDAYS, RAYMOND.
WE ARE THE NIGHT BEFORE
THANKSGIVING.
HAPPY THANKSGIVING TO BOTH OF
YOU.
I AM ONE OF THE BIGGEST LIBERALS
IN AMERICA AND THANKSGIVING IS
ONE OF THE THINGS WE ALL
CELEBRATE.
IT WILL GET LOST IN THE
HOLIDAYS.
THE NEW YEAR WILL ROLL AROUND.
THERE WILL BE A TRIAL IN THE
SENATE.
EVERYBODY WILL READ THE BOTTOM
OF PAGE 3 AND THE TOP OF PAGE 4
OF THE TRANSCRIPT AND THE
PRESIDENT HELD UP THE UKRAINIAN
PRESIDENT FOR DIRT ON HIS
POLITICAL OPPONENT.
THAT'S AS SLAM DUNK AS YOU NEED
TO GET.
>> I WANT TO SHOW YOU BEFORE I
GO TO THE NEXT QUESTION.
I HAVE TO SHARE WHAT WE GOT IN
NEW YORK CITY ON THE STREET.
THE MEDIA IS SALIVATING OVER
THIS "NEW YORK TIMES" REPORT
THAT TRUMP WAS BRIEFED ON THE
WHISTLEBLOWER COMPLAINT BEFORE
RELEASING AID TO THE UKRAINE.
LISTEN TO THIS.
>> THE ONLY REASON HE RELEASED
THE AID IS HE GOT CAUGHT IN THIS
WHOLE SCHEME.
>> THE PRESIDENT RELEASED THE
AID WHEN HE KNEW HIS COVER WAS
BLOWN.
>> ONCE THEY KNEW THE GIG WAS
UP, THEY HAD THE DEFENSE OF WE
GAVE HIM THE AID.
NO HARM NO FOUL.
>> IT MAY HAVE TO DO WITH HIS
CONVERSATION WITH A MEMBER OF
THE UKRAINIAN CAUCUS.
THIS IS HOW THE PRESIDENT
EXPLAINED IT.
>> HE SAID PLEASE LET THE MONEY
GO.
I SAID ROB, I HATE BEING THE
COUNTRY THAT IS ALWAYS GIVING
MONEY.
WHEN UKRAINE HELPS THE EUROPEAN
COUNTRY MORE THAN THEY HELP US.
THAT'S MY ONLY REASON.
I DON'T LIKE BEING THE SUCKER
COUNTRY.
>> IS THE IDEA THE PRESIDENT WAS
BRIEFED BEFORE HE RELEASED THIS
AID AND TOLD ABOUT THE
WHISTLEBLOWER COMPLAINT IS THAT
THE SILVER BULLET TO TAKE HIM
OUT?
>> [LAUGHING].
LISTEN, I LOVE YOU, RAYMOND.
THIS CASE IS A JOKE!
YOU GUYS ARE HUMILIATING
YOURSELF ON THE LEFT RUNNING
WITH THIS.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND HOW YOU
DIDN'T LEARN FROM THE CLINTON
IMPEACHMENT WHAT A DEBACLE THIS
WILL BE.
YOU ARE GOING TO GET TRUMP
REELECTED.
THE SILVER BULLET, OR QUID PRO
QUO, YOU HAVE TO HAVE SOMEONE ON
THE ARE THE END WHO IS AWARE OF
THE BRIBERY OR THE QUID PRO QUO.
NO UKRAINIAN OFFICIAL BACKED UP
THIS STORY.
IT'S A FABRICATED SCANDAL.
>> CHRIS, YOUR REACTION?
>> DAN, THE CONGRESS
APPROPRIATED THIS MONEY AND THE
PRESIDENT SIGNED THE BILL.
THERE IS THE IMPOUNDMENT CONTROL
ACT THAT THE PRESIDENT VIOLATED
BY NOT INFORMING CONGRESS HE WAS
HOLDING THIS MONEY UP.
>> NOT NECESSARILY, CHRIS.
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING].
>> THAT'S NOT TRUE.
>> IT'S ABSOLUTELY TRUE!
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING].
>> OKAY, DON'T TALK OVER EACH
OTHER.
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING].
>> STOP.
NOBODY CAN HEAR YOU WHEN YOU ARE
TALKING OVER EACH OTHER.
>> IF THE PRESIDENT HAD ANY
COURAGE AT ALL, HE WOULD LET HIS
AIDS SPEAK TO CONGRESS AND GET
IT OUT THERE.
>> OKAY, CHRIS.
DAN, GO AHEAD.
>> CHRIS IS JUST MAKING THAT UP
AGAIN.
LIBERALS ARE GOOD AT THAT.
EVERYTHING IS IN REVERSE.
OF COURSE YOU ARE MAKING IT UP.
THE PRESIDENT DICTATES WHERE
FOREIGN AID GOES.
>> GUYS --
>> YOU ARE JUST MAKING THAT UP.
THIS IS NOT AN OPEN AND SHUT
CASE.
IT'S NOT A CASE AT ALL.
>> TO PROVE THE CASE AND TO MAKE
THIS NEW BOMBSHELL STICK YOU
WOULD HAVE TO GET INTO TRUMP'S
MIND.
THAT'S A HARD THING TO MOVE.
GENTLEMEN, I WANT TO SHARE WITH
YOU HOW PEOPLE ARE REACTING.
REAL AMERICANS ON THE STREET TO
THIS IMPEACHMENT DRAMA.
WHEN I ASKED THEM ARE YOU GOING
TO BE FOCUSSED ON THE HOLIDAYS
OR ON NADLER AND THE
IMPEACHMENT?
WATCH.
>> THIS CHRISTMAS SEASON WILL
YOU BE FOCUSSED ON IMPEACHMENT
OR SANTA CLAUS AND THE HOLIDAYS?
>> THE HOLIDAYS.
>> ABSOLUTELY SANTA CLAUS.
>> SANTA.
>> SANTA CLAUS AND GETTING RID
OF THE DEMOCRATS.
>> IMPEACHMENT, ABSOLUTELY
IMPEACHMENT.
>> WHY?
>> BECAUSE IT'S IMPORTANT.
>> YOU WON'T BE FOCUSSED ON
IMPEACHMENT?
>> WILL NOT.
>> IT'S A WASTE OF TIME.
>> A WASTE OF TIME.
>> YOU WILL BE JINGLE BELLING
ALL THE WAY.
>> I WILL GO TO 34th STREET AND
SEE IF THERE IS A MIRACLE THERE.
>> CHRIS, ISN'T IT A HARD CASE
TO MAKE?
WHY DO YOU THINK THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE ARE WALKING AWAY FROM
THIS?
>> WELL, 2% MOVEMENT IN THE POLL
IS NOT WALKING AWAY.
>> IT'S 3%.
IT'S JUST NUMBERS.
>> IT'S INSIGNIFICANT, RAYMOND.
IT IS THE HOLIDAYS.
AFTER THIS HIT TONIGHT, I AM NOT
TALKING ABOUT POLITICS UNTIL
MONDAY AND I ENCOURAGE EVERY
AMERICAN TO DO THE SAME THING.
LEAVE IT ALONE.
IT WILL BE WAITING FOR YOU ON
MONDAY.
RELAX AND HAVE A NICE HOLIDAY
AND HAVE A NICE CHRISTMAS SEASON
AND DON'T GET TOO BOGGED DOWN IN
THIS.
I DIDN'T WANT TO GO BACK TO A
TIME WHERE WE DIDN'T THINK ABOUT
THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES EVERY MINUTE.
>> CHRIS, DAN AND I WOULD
SUPPORT THAT.
IN THE SPIRIT OF THANKSGIVING, A
LEFT WING GROUP MOVE ON.ORG IS
URGING FOLLOWERS TO TALK TO YOUR
FAMILY ABOUT IMPEACHMENT THIS
THANKSGIVING.
IS THIS A GOOD IDEA?
>> OH!
PLEASE, I AM BEGGING YOU
DON'T -- CHRIS AND I RARELY
AGREE ON ANYTHING.
WHEN CHRIS AND I AND THE HOST
RAYMOND AGREE.
DO NOT DO THIS!
>> THIS IS A MOMENT OF GRACE.
>> AMERICA, DO NOT TAKE THAT
ADVICE!
>> OKAY, WE WILL HAVE A
CEASEFIRE.
>> HOLD IT FOR A COUPLE OF DAYS.
>> WE ARE HAVING A THANKSGIVING
CEASEFIRE.
WE WILL JUST WATCH FOOTBALL AND
EAT TURKEY AND LOVE OUR FAMILY.